once we were all dressed by someone else
parents picked out a t-shirt the school
dictated what color our trousers should
be but at some point we were granted the
opportunity to discover who we might be
in the world of clothes we had to decide
for ourselves about colors and necklines
fit colors patterns textures and what
goes or doesn't with what we learn to
speak about ourselves in the language of
garments despite the potential silliness
an exaggeration of sections of the
fashion industry assembling a wardrobe
is a serious and meaningful exercise
based on our looks or background others
are always liable to come to a quick and
not very rounded decisions about who we
are too often that judgment doesn't
quite get us right they might assume
that because of where we come from we
must be quite snobbish or rather
resentful based on our work we might get
typecast as doula or superficial the
fact that we're very sporty might lead
people to see us as not terribly
intelligent or an attachment to a
particular political outlook might be
associated with being unnerving ly
earnest clothes providers with a major
opportunity to correct some of these
assumptions when we get dressed we are
in effect operating as a tour guide
offering to show people around ourselves
we're highlighting interesting or
attractive things about who we are and
in the process we're clearing up
misconceptions we're acting like artists
painting a self-portrait deliberately
guiding the viewers perception of who
they might be
in 1961 the English painter Peter Blake
portrayed himself wearing a denim jacket
jeans and trainers he was deliberately
new asking the view most of his
contemporaries would have had of him
based on knowing that he was successful
and rather intellectual painter he might
have been thought of as slightly aloof
and highly refined detached from and
since aureus of ordinary life but his
clothes speak about very different
aspects of his personality they go out
of their way to tell us that he's quite
modest he's interested in talking about
pop music he sees his art
as a kind of manual labor his clothes
like ours give us a crucial introduction
to the self this explains the curious
phenomenon whereby if we're staying with
good friends we can spend a lot less
time thinking about our clothes compared
with the anxiety about what to wear that
can grip us with strangers with good
friends we might sit around in a
dressing-gown or just hastily slip on
any old jumper they know who we are
already and they're not relying on our
clothes for clues it's a strange but
profound fact that certain items of
clothing can excite us when we put them
on or see others wearing them when
turned on a particular style of jacket
the right kind of shoes or the perfect
shirt might prove so erotic we could
almost do without a person wearing them
it's tempting to see this kind of
fetishism as simply deluded but it is
alerting us in an exaggerated way to a
much more general and very normal idea
that certain clothes make us very happy
they capture values that were drawn and
want to get closer to the erotic
component is just an extension of a more
general and understandable sympathy the
French novelist stardoll wrote Beauty is
the promise of happiness and every item
of clothing were drawn to contains an
allusion to a different sort of
happiness we might see a very desirable
kind of competence and confidence in a
particular pair of boots we might meet
generosity in a woolen coat or a
touching kind of innocence in a hemline
a particular watch strap may sum up
dignity the way specific collar in cases
the neck could strike us as commanding
and authoritative the classic fetishist
might be pushing their particular
attachments to a maximum and be rather
restricted in a choice of items they
favor but they are latching on to a
general theme clothes embody values that
enchant and beguile us by choosing
particular sorts of clothes
we are shoring up our more fragile or
tentative characteristics
we're both communicating to others about
who we are and strategically reminding
ourselves our wardrobes contain some of
our most carefully written lines
of autobiography
you